[موسيقى]
هجمات في العمق الروسي تقول موسكو ان
بصمات الجيش الاوكراني جاليه عليها
تنفيكييف وتقول انها من فعل مجموعات
معارضه لحكم بوتين وبتتبع مسار هذه
الهجمات نلحظ تصاعدا في عددها وقواتها
وجراه اكبر في اسلوب تنفيذها مقاطعه
بيلكرود على بعد اربعين كيلو مترا شرقي
الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه هنا كانت اكثر
الهجمات دمويه حين فتح مهاجمان النار داخل
معسكر تدريب للمتطوعين الراغبين في القتال
باوكرانيا اوقع احد عشر قتيلا وبمرور شهور
الحرب تحولت مقاطعه بالقرود ومعها مقاطعه
بيريانسك الواقعه على بعد 60 كيلومترا من
الحدود مع اوكرانيا هدفين لهجمات صاروخيه
وعلى فترات متفاوته اوقعت قتلى وجرحى
الطائرات المسيره اكثر جراه من الهجمات
الصاروخيه بعد ذلك في الهجوم على الكرملين
بدايه الشهر الحالي بطائرتين مسيرتين
بينما اعلنت الطوارئ الروسيه العثور على
مسيره ثالثه مفخخه في ضواحي موسكو كذلك
الهجوم على ماطرين عسكريين في منطقتين
على بعد مئات الكيلومترات من ساحه المعركه
في اوكرانيا ما اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه جنود
روس اما التوغل داخل الاراضي الروسيه فهو
سيناريو توبع مرات عده منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا حدث ذلك حين تسللت مجموعه مسلحه
الى احدى قرى المقاطعه الروسيه واحتجزت
رهائن داخل احد المتاجر اما اخطر عمليه
تسلل فكانت خلال الساعات الماضيه حين
اقتحمت مجموعتان مسلحتان بالقرود وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها تصدت للهجوم
وقتلت عشرات من المهاجمين وقد اعلن ما
يعرف بفيلق حريه روسيا مسؤوليته عن الهجوم
في بيلجرود الروايه نفسها تجزم بها
المخابرات الاوكرانيه بالقول ان الفيلقين
روسيين معارضين للكرملين هما فيلق حريه
روسيا وفيلق المتطوعين الروس ينفذان عمليه
داخل بالقرود لانشاء ما تسميه كييف منطقه
امنيه لحمايه المدنيين الاوكرانيين